El 15 de julio de este año el ejército
turco se levantó contra su propio
gobierno.
No es la primera vez que pasa, en
realidad es la quinta en menos de 50
años.
A este paso los golpes de estado en
Turquía van a convertirse en una
tradición local como lo es comer
baklava o visitar santa sofía.
Hoy vamos a explicar  de dónde
viene este golpe de estado y qué
consecuencias puede tener y lo vamos a
hacer por dos razones primero porque nos
lo habéis pedido y segundo porque es un
tema muy importante que apenas lo han
cubierto los medios de comunicación, al
menos en España.
Lo cierto es que es muy difícil
determinar quiénes son los buenos en
esta historia,
por un lado es cierto que el ejército
ha intentado atacar a un gobierno
elegido democráticamente, pero por el
otro
Erdogán es a la democracia lo mismo que
la salchipapa esa a la canción pop
melódica.
Sin embargo este intento de golpe de
estado es probablemente la noticia más
importante de este verano y por eso es
muy importante que entendamos todo el
trasfondo político que hay detrás.
-"Si queréis profundizar más en el golpe de estado
turco
os recomendamos que veáis el vídeo que
ha hecho Mister x en su canal,
se trata de un canal amigo dedicado a la
geopolítica. Encontraréis el link en la
descripción de este vídeo.
¿Por qué turquía es tan
importante?
Turquía tiene 80 millones de habitantes,
casi la población de Alemania.
Además, su ejército es el segundo más
grande de la OTAN sólo superado por el
de estados unidos.
Por si esto fuera poco Turquía es uno de los
pocos países de mayoría musulmana que
tiene una constitución completamente
laica y esto lleva siendo así desde que
se creó el propio estado turco, después
de la primera guerra mundial.
Su primer presidente y padre de la
patria Mustafa Kemal Atatürk diseñó
una estado a imagen y semejanza de Europa.
Es más, llegó a prohibir vestimentas
típicamente musulmanas como el fez y a
promover toda clase de programas que
fomentaran la vestimenta occidental. Por
supuesto eliminó cualquier vestigio de
ley islámica del corpus legal turco. El
precio de todas estas reformas fue la
represión de cualquier minoría que no
encajará bien con el modelo de estado
que Atatürk tenía en la cabeza. Para eso
se sirvió de un ejército enorme con
una gran capacidad de influencia en las
decisiones políticas.
Eso explica todos estos golpes de estado.
De hecho, durante todos estos años en
Turquía se han creado dos bandos:
por un lado están los llamados turcos
blancos que son úrbanos, laicos y
normalmente trabajan en la
administración pública; por el otro
estarían los turcos negros que son
rurale,s mucho más pobres y no ven
demasiado bien eso de la separación
iglesia-estado.
Respecto a la economía
Turquía nunca ha terminado de despegar.
En fin ya sabéis que en visual
política no somos muy amigos de la
intervención del estado en la economía
pero es que el caso turco es un ejemplo
de libro de lo que ocurre cuando todos
los sectores de la economía están
centralizados en el estado. Pero es que
Turquía es el ejemplo del libro de lo
que ocurre cuando casi todos los actores
de la economía están centralizadas en
el estado.
El resultado es corrupción, tráfico de
influencias y una élite de
privilegiados que tienen contacto con la
clase dirigente y viven mucho mejor que
los que no lo tienen. Todo esto regado
con la salsa picante de la inflación.
Esto es el resumen de lo que ha sido
Turquía a lo largo del siglo 20
pero esperad un momento, porque en el
año 2003 llega el hombre destinado a
rescatar a este país de sus cenizas.
Erdogán era uno de esos
turcos negros que pasaba más tiempo en
la mezquita que axl rose en alcohólicos
anónimos.
De hecho, cuando era alcalde de Estambul
pasó diez meses en la cárcel por haber
leído en público un poema que
supuestamente incitaba a la intolerancia
religiosa.
Nada más salir de prisión creó un
nuevo partido político al que llamó
Justicia y Libertad que supuestamente
era laico.
En 2003 ganó las elecciones y se
convirtió en primer ministro;
su primer objetivo fue acabar con la
inflación y esto no es ninguna
tontería porque, mirad, cuando hablamos de
inflación
normalmente parece que es esa cosa que
solamente importa a los grandes
empresarios, pero es lo que más nos
afecta en nuestro día a día.
Imaginad por un momento que vivieraís en Ankara en enero del año 2001 y
comprarais una barra de pan por el precio
de dos líneas turcas,
seis meses después esa barra de pan
costaría el doble y lo mismo con el
resto de cosas que quisiesemos comprar.
Sin embargo, a lo mejor hasta el año que
viene no nos van a subir el sueldo.
Menuda putada ¿verdad? Pues eso era el
pan nuestro de cada día,
nunca mejor dicho, en Turquía. Erdogán
le puso punto final a la inflación y lo
hizo gracias a liberalizar muchos
sectores de la economía y privatizar
muchas de las empresas publicas.
- "Aproximadamente el 85% de las personas
que votaron al partido Justicia y
Progreso lo hicieron por la economía."
Durante estos años
turquía se convirtió en la China de
Europa. Empresas como Ikea o Inditex
abrieron muchísimas fábricas
aprovechando los salarios bajos y su
economía estaba on fire. Estambul se
puso de moda como destino turístico y
de hecho, si prestáis atención,
veréis que entre 2005 y 2010 hay un
montón de películas comerciales que
están ambientadas en esta ciudad.
De hecho, los que seguís Visual Politik
desde hace tiempo
recordareis un video que hicimos hablando
de las ciudades que más han crecido, en
el top 5 3 eran ciudades turcas. Pero
sin duda el mejor símbolo de este
milagro económico sería Turkish
Airlines, una aerolínea que hace 20
años era un poquito del montón y que
hoy en día es una de las más grandes
del mundo codeándose con otras como
Lufthansa o Emirates.
Este boom turco llegó a tal punto que
hasta en la Unión Europea se planteaban
incluir Turquía entre los estados
miembros.
Erdogán se convirtió en un modelo a
seguir para todos los países musulmanes,
era el ejemplo viviente de cómo se
puede combinar islam con democracia y
crecimiento económico.
-" Su llegada a la capital
egipcia parece la recepción de un
héroe." Pero esperad un momento, porque
en 2003 las cosas empezaron a torcerse.
- "La otra cara de Erdogán." Como hemos visto
Erdogán se había convertido en un sex
symbol del mundo árabe y eso le molaba.
Durante las primaveras árabes Turquía
jugó un rol muy importante para poner y
quitar dictadores, especialmente en su
vecina Siria.
Lo cierto es que Erdogán nunca ha hecho
buenas migas con Al Asad, así que, en
cuanto tuvo la oportunidad, ayudó a
cualquier fuerza que atacará al dictador
sirio, y sí, eso incluye el Daesh.
- "Ankara rechazó tomar partido en acciones
militares directas contra los militantes
del estado islámico."
El problema que tiene llevarse bien con
él Daesh es que nunca te devuelven los
favores,
así que Erdogán hizo la vista gorda en
la frontera de Siria con Turquía y los
del estado islámico aprovecharon para
cruzar como pedro por su casa y
dedicarse a reclutar militantes en
tierra turca. ¿El resultado? Más de 195
muertos en once atentados terroristas
y todo esto en sólo dos años. Por si
esto fuera poco, en 2013 aparecieron
varios casos de corrupción que
apuntaban directamente a Erdogán y
aquí es donde la antigua rockstar del
mundo musulmán
nos mostró su cara más autoritaria.
- "Turquía bloquea temporalmente twitter y
youtube y amenaza con prohibir úber."
¡Ojo! Que esta noticia es de un año antes
del intento de golpe de estado, pero no
sólo eso, es que desde el año 2010
Erdogán ha metido en la cárcel a más
de 82 periodistas.
Es más, según el Índice de Libertad de
Expresión realizado por Periodistas Sin
Fronteras
Turquía está por debajo de otros
paraísos de la censura como lo pueden
ser Rusia, Etiopía o México. Pero eso no
es nada comparado con lo que hemos
descubierto la semana pasada.
Erdogán hizo un llamamiento a su
población para que resistieran al golpe
de estado del ejército turco.
Hasta ahí normal, el problema es cómo
lo hizo.
- "Los ciudadanos turcos recibieron un sms
que les pedía que salieran a la calle
para resistir el golpe de estado" ¡Un sms!
¡A su móvil personal! O sea que Erdogán
tiene una base de datos con todos los
números de todos los ciudadanos turcos
y no tiene ningún reparo en utilizarla.
Muy poquitos dictadores han llegado a
tener semejante control sobre su
población.
Esto deja al mismísimo Vladimir Putin a
la altura de un premio nobel de la paz,
por eso es tan difícil considerar a
Erdogán como un líder democrático
aunque haya ganado unas elecciones y
todo esto por no hablar de las medidas
de excepción que está tomando después
del golpe de estado que darían para
otro vídeo.
Pero ¿vosotros qué pensáis? ¿Quién es el
bueno en esta película?
¿El ejército que se ha cargado a más de
200 ciudadanos en menos de un fin de
semana o este nuevo gran hermano turco
al que llamamos Erdogán?
La verdad es que ya no lo tengo nada
claro. Podéis déjame vuestra opinión en
los comentarios que como siempre deriva
en un debate superdivertido, los que
conoceis a este canal lo sabes muy bien.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo darle
a like y suscribiros al canal si no lo habeis hecho todavía.
Para este mes que viene
estamos preparando un montón de temas
que os van a encantar,
así que de verdad suscribiros porque va
a merecer la pena. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.